when you think of islands you might
think of pristine beaches and palm trees
gently swaying along with a warm breeze
sounds like paradise and as a scientist
islands are my kind of place for
research
islands are very beautiful and they also
have a lot of biodiversity biodiversity
can be described as the variety of
species in an ecosystem
now some ecosystems have higher
biodiversity than others but all
ecosystems have a variety of species
that interact in specific ways with one
another
islands have such a variety of species
that they're often called biodiversity
hot spots they're home to so many
diverse species much more so than the
continents
there are nearly half a million islands
around the world but they only make up
about five percent of the earth's land
area yet islands are home to 20 percent
of the world's plant species and 15
percent of all mammal bird and amphibian
species
many of these island species can only be
found on one island or within a group of
islands
for example you can only find the eevee
a honey creeper bird species and the
main hawaiian islands in the north
pacific ocean
the eev are important pollinator species
for hawaiian plants including the opelu
and ohia pollination is an essential
part of plant reproduction allowing
plants to produce their fruits and seeds
while the eevee feeds on the sweet
nectar of these plants this bird also
helps to support the next generation of
opelu and ohia
these and other types of interactions
are happening all the time between
species and an ecosystem you can think
of biodiversity as a sort of safety net
with each species as a knot and the
ropes between knots as their
interactions the diversity of species
and their interactions hold the net
together allowing the ecosystem to
function
plus the relationships between species
are often unique
for example the eev has a special curved
bill and it's evolved to feed on the
nectar of very specific flowers that are
similarly curved like the opelu
now even though the eev is highly
adapted to its environment if something
happens to the opelu or ohia and these
plants start to decline it can spell
disaster for the eev
when an ecosystem changes so much that a
species can no longer survive that
species may become extinct or die out
causing biodiversity to decrease
and unfortunately many of hawaii's
honeycreepers and overall biodiversity
have been lost through extinction
in the past there were at least 20 other
species of honey creeper found across
hawaii
but many of them have become extinct
over time
if we return to our analogy of
biodiversity as a safety net whenever a
species goes extinct it's like a knot
becomes undone and parts of the net
start to fall apart
a decrease in biodiversity is often a
result of human activities which is
especially clear in the hawaiian islands
in the last few hundred years
agriculture grazing logging and
development have taken almost half of
hawaii's forest cover and along with a
big part of its biodiversity
humans have also brought non-native
animals like rats and feral pigs to
hawaii which have changed or destroyed
native habitats plus new diseases and
climate change have led to the
extinction of many hawaiian species
when an ecosystem loses biodiversity it
doesn't function as well
if ohia starts to disappear from
hawaiian forests it's not just the eevee
that loses an important food source
but the entire ecosystem is affected in
fact scientists often look at how
complete an ecosystem's biodiversity is
in order to measure the ecosystem's
health the safety net of biodiversity is
supported by having lots of different
species which allows the ecosystem to
cope with natural disasters like drought
storms and disease
with more biodiversity ecosystems are
stronger and more resilient so they can
recover quickly
but with less biodiversity ecosystems
become more vulnerable i've told you a
lot about how hawaii is losing
biodiversity however there is cause for
some hope
the nene or hawaiian goose nearly went
extinct there were less than 30 birds in
the wild 50 years ago now thanks to lots
of conservation work to improve the
habitat for this species there are over
3 000 nene throughout the islands
we humans are part of earth's
biodiversity too we are components of
the ecosystems we touch so if we have
the power to hurt these ecosystems we
have the power to protect and heal them
too aloha